Speaker 1: All right, let's jump into a sort
of very strange interview that Fox News host
Greg Gutfeld did on on his show. I don't know
if this is still a comedy show or not. It
has a laugh track. It sounds like it's a very
strange show. Now, I've exchanged some messages
with Greg Gutfeld in the past. And sometimes
when we talk about things he does and point
out how ridiculous and humiliating they are,
he'll tweet and say, you know, this wasn't
good or something like that. So I understand
Gutfeld may may see this and he may not like
it. What was notable about this interview
that he had is that it was with the former
president, Donald Trump, often in interviews
with Trump. Trump's the only guy who's humiliated.
But in this interview, it's both Trump and
Gutfeld. This is this is maybe this would
make Maria Bartiromo blush. It's so fawning
and brownnosing of Donald Trump. The interview
opens with Gutfeld basically saying he loves
Trump and his even like his prior critiques
of things Trump said were maybe like not fair.
It's very strange. Check this out.
Speaker 4: Right. And then you started and
now I think I don't know if it's love, but
it's getting close and we like it.
Speaker 5: I wouldn't say it's love, but I
would say it's admiration. And also admitting
that I was wrong because I was focusing on
words and not deeds. And now we're at a time
where, OK, there are no mean tweets and we
have a really nice president
Speaker 1: because he's been banned from Twitter
Speaker 5: and the country is in the crapper.
So who would you rather have?
Speaker 4: Well, I don't know that he's a
nice president.
Speaker 1: What is what is the laughing like?
Is this is there a studio audience that's
reacting? Is it a laugh track? Is this a comedy
show? Is it a news show? It's all very weird.
It's not working as either, quite frankly,
Speaker 4: that I can tell you, the country
has never been more unsafe. We have people
pouring in through our southern border, which
everyone
Speaker 1: been talking about. That's not
true
Speaker 4: getting about right now because
of the travesty of Afghanistan. And if you
look at the people coming in, but it's
Speaker 1: like you, Gutfeld, instead of saying.
Right. Could so easily disable that and diffuse
it and say, oh, how have the numbers changed
of people coming in and how have deportation
numbers changed? And, you know, give it give
us that. Trump would say, well, I don't know,
but it's just it's really bad. Just just look
just look
Speaker 4: hundreds by the thousands. And
these are not the people necessarily that
wanted the protection. Right. These are people.
So are they terrorists? How many terrorists
are coming in? And they were aggressive, very
aggressive at the plane and they push,
Speaker 1: Gutfeld is saying, right. And yes
to every single thing. Trump says after talking
about how great Trump is. Gutfeld then asked
Trump, What would you say to my wife to convince
her to get vaccinated? Apparently, Gutfeld
wife isn't vaccinated. And Trump goes, well,
I recommend it, but if she doesn't want to,
she shouldn't like he's he still has to be
careful because if he really says, like, just
get vaccinated, his audience will go nuts.
Speaker 5: Because you had covid and my wife,
you met my wife, I don't know, like six years
ago in Mar a Lago. She's still not gotten
vaccinated. And I keep talking to her to get
her to Vatan and get vaccinated and she hasn't.
What would you say to her?
Speaker 4: Well, first of all, I say, why
is she not doing it? Does she have some kind
of religious thing?
Speaker 5: No skeptical she doesn't trust?
Speaker 1: Well, I think there was a laugh
like there was laughing when Trump asked why,
if someone's using a laugh track, it's being
used that very strange times brushing.
Speaker 5: Yes. She said at the end of that,
you can't argue with the Russian.
Speaker 4: Very smart. Yeah, very hard headed.
Yes. I think I know your wife a little bit,
right? Yes, but she's got.
Speaker 1: Twenty seconds ago, Trump seemed
not to remember meeting her, but now Trump
is talking about how well he knows Gutfeld
wife could. Is this considered a news interview
Speaker 4: and let her do what she wants to
do? I got vaccinated. Yeah, I feel very good.
I think we saved millions and millions of
people worldwide. You know, in 1917,
Speaker 1: they say it's 1918, almost
Speaker 4: one hundred million, approximately
one hundred million people died. Yeah, I think
we could have been into that situation because
it was very bad. And now if you vaccinated,
the other thing, it shows that if you do get
sick, you don't get sick like they were before,
meaning you don't die.
Speaker 1: Except Trump's right about all
this, by the way.
Speaker 4: So I would recommend. But I also
say that let her have her freedom and see
another word.
Speaker 5: Freedom, right? Yeah, I would you
she needs freedom. Oh, she needs a lot of
freedom for me. I found
Speaker 1: her. Gutfeld The premise was how
can I convince my wife to get vaccinated?
But as soon as Trump says her freedom not
to get vaccinated is important, Gutfeld says,
yeah, exactly. There's nothing Trump said
during this interview. We're Gutfeld wasn't
like, well, hold well, hold on a second here,
then. The questioning gets really tough. Gutfeld
asked Trump, how hard is it to be president
from one to two? Was it a difficult job question?
Speaker 5: No one's ever asked you this. I
think I might know the answer.
Speaker 1: Well, a five year old would ask
this. Donald, is it hard to be the press that
this is what a little kid would ask? So it's
not? Nobody is. No, no reporter or journalist
would ask such a dumb question.
Speaker 5: How hard is it being being president
from a scale to one to 10? Well, I had now
Speaker 1: hear the laughing. Makes sense,
right? The question is so stupid that I actually
think there was not enough laughing here.
Speaker 4: Two forms of presidency. No one
had to run the country, work on the world
and do things. And the other thing I had to
survive. Yeah, the survivor was much tougher.
Speaker 1: Listen, he was busy not only being
president, but trying to keep up with golfing,
watching TV and fending off sexual assault
lawsuits. Really tough stuff. And then here's
just the last clip. In this one, Trump suggests
that Taliban leaders, when he speaks, speaks
to them on the phone, that they grunt. Now,
what's funny is supposedly Biden would be
bad for dealing with the Taliban here. Trump
talks about when he would deal with the Taliban,
but it's all about calling them Abdul and
saying they grunt all
Speaker 4: this Christmas is Christmas is
still celebrating. OK, so I told you about
Abdul stuff. And when I first spoke to him
by phone, I said, nice to speak to you by
phone, Abdul. And he goes, I know they're
ferocious people. You know, like you go to
Broadway shows, they fight, they like to fight.
They've been fighting for about a thousand
years.
Speaker 1: How they hate. What a humiliating
interview. And then now I'm in and now dropping
the cherry on top. This is like nothing I've
ever seen. Gutfeld says yes to everything.
He opens the interview by saying how great
Trump is. He asks questions like how hard
was it to be president? From one to ten, he
says, right to everything, Trump says. And
then this guy named Titus or Tyrus Tyrus,
I think it is, who has a wrestling belt. He's,
I guess, a panelist on this program. He says,
you know what was great about this interview,
Greg Gutfeld? You didn't kiss Trump's ass
tirhas. Did you watch the interview? It's
beyond parody.
Speaker 2: Take a look. Normally would never
do this, man. But wow, man, that was that
was a hard one. But it was it was a conversation.
And you didn't change. No people in the interview.
President change. You didn't kiss his ass.
Speaker 1: What what did you see the interview
Speaker 2: and I applaud you. You got a great
you had a conversation. You even told him
I didn't like I used to hear more. This guy,
this guy. And that was it. That was a great
conversation.
Speaker 1: It is it is truly beyond parody.
And it is just stunning that this I mean,
what that interview would have made Maria
Bartiromo blush. That's how much of a of a
sycophant brownnosing interview it was. I
I hope Gutfeld feels humiliated because he
should. It was a humiliating interview.